- [Parnab Basak] Welcome
to day one of "re:Invent".
If you have not already been
to a day-one events before,
this is the day you realize
that there is more in Vegas
than just its casinos.
This is also a day you realize
that your biggest friend
are your sneakers,
while finding rooms in Vegas.
And this is also a day you realize
that jet lag is real, okay?
So, just raise of hands,
how many of you are jet-lagged already?
Because you are already,
okay, I see a lot of it.
That's nothing you should be shy about.
I'm jet-lagged too and I am
in central time zone, okay?
So, I can understand from people
that are traveling all across the world.
So, this session is not
about jet lag or your shoes or your Vegas.
- [Tom Romano] Or the need for chapstick.
- [Parnab Basak] Yeah, or a
need for chapsticks either,
okay?
So, this session,
is about building fault-tolerant
messaging systems,
using AWS services.
A quick show of hands,
how many of you are using,
or planning to use an
AWS messaging service
in your workloads in any shape or format?
I see, okay, Plad, you
are in the right room.
Trust me, this is the talk
on AWS messaging services.
So, on that same note, let
me ask you another question.
How many of you have been,
had to handle outages in
your messaging systems
and you have to be called
in the middle of the night,
middle of your weekend or
middle of your non-working hours
to handle a complex issue?
I see one there.
- [Tom Romano] Yeah.
- [Parnab Basak] I see a
few more rising up, okay.
- [Tom Romano] Over
there, lots over there.
- [Parnab Basak] Yeah, hopefully,
this session and the
learnings from it help you
to not be in that situation anymore.
So, with that, let me introduce myself.
I'm Parnab Basak.
I'm a senior solutions architect,
helping out our public-sector
customers adopt AWS
for their needs.
And I'm a developer at heart.
With me is Tom.
Tom?
- [Tom Romano] Hi, my name's Tom Romano.
I'm also a senior solutions architect.
I've been working with Parnab
for about five years now.
And we are both members
of a serverless technical field community.
- [Parnab Basak] Hmm.
- [Tom Romano] And I'm also a member
of the analytics
technical field community.
- [Parnab Basak] Wow!
- [Tom Romano] In data engineering,
we use these patterns a lot as well.
- [Parnab Basak] Awesome!
So, what you mean to say Tom,
is you can imply this if
you're running a data pipeline,
or a messaging service, you
can imply all these patterns-
- [Tom Romano] Yes.
- [Parnab Basak] There?
- [Tom Romano] Yep.
- [Parnab Basak] Fantastic,
so, you get two for one, okay,
like all the Black Friday
sales, buy one, get one free.
So, there's a BOGO offer.
Okay, let's go with what we
have in plan today, okay?
So, we're gonna talk
about very briefly, okay,
about what the AWS messaging services are,
the patterns of it.
Again, this is a code
talk, a 300 level at that.
So, most of the time,
the hopeless Tom is going to live-code
in front of this big of an audience, okay,
without using generative AI, okay?
And please say a prayer for him
(Tom laughs)
and let the demo gods be still be with him
during the latter part of the session.
- [Tom Romano] And I never had-
- [Parnab Basak] I get
to get the easiest part,
talk about the slide deck, right?
So, we're gonna talk about some
of the resiliency considerations
you should worry about,
while designing messaging
patterns and systems.
We'll talk about patterns,
which is the highlight of your talk.
And then, code and of course, Q&A.
Again, keep those Q&A coming.
We would need some time to deploy.
So, that's the time that we can ask
for any feedback questions,
talking about your architecture,
something that you have
learned would be useful.
So, with that, let's level-set, okay?
You might be already using these services.
You might already have
used these services before.
So, if you look at AWS messaging services,
this deck probably encompasses everything.
So, we have AWS-native services
and there is a bunch of those.
We have event stores,
we have event routers.
You can look at simple
queuing service or Amazon SQS
for FIFO queues, standard
queues, et cetera,
or if you're willing to go
use a topic-based system
for pub/sub messaging patterns,
you can use Amazon Simple
Notification Service.
If you're looking at a streaming service,
Amazon Kinesis with all its variations,
does give you that streaming interface.
And if you're looking for
an enterprise service bus
for point-to-point integrations,
you can look at Amazon
EventBridge as well.
Then, comes another set of services
that we call that AWS
managed open-source services.
What we have done is taken
their open-source code
and given you
as customers, as users, as
developers, an access to those
through a managed interface,
so that you don't have worry
about setting that yourself
on an EC2 instance.
So, this comes in two forms.
You have Amazon MQ or
Message Queing services.
It has two support for both
the RabbitMQ and ActiveMQ.
So, if you are building
those hybrid architectures,
bringing in your existing
RabbitMQ or ActiveMQ over to AWS,
you can look at Amazon MQ as an option.
And then,
you have Amazon Managed Streaming
Service for Apache Kafka.
Again, that's a mouthful of a name.
So, we call it Amazon MSK,
also gives you that managed platform
if you are planning to use
Kafka within your architecture.
So, just a quick raise of hands,
how many of you are using
an AWS-native service?
I see a few there, few here as well.
How many of you use managed
open-source service?
Okay.
Just by count of hands, roughly,
it seems there's a more inclination
to use an AWS-native service,
which is perfectly okay.
Now, both of these patterns
are good to implement depending
on what you are doing.
But during our talk,
we're gonna use more of
this AWS-native approach.
But we will also sprinkling in some ideas
about managed open-source services too.
So, everybody probably knows
what an architecture or components
of a messaging service looks like.
You have a producer, you have
a consumer, as simple as that.
In between, you have a messaging service
that can be a router, that can be a topic,
that can be an event bus, doesn't matter.
If you look at this architecture,
when you talk about resiliency
of this architecture,
'cause nobody wants to get
pinged at 12:00 AM at night,
you have multiple points of failure.
Your producer can go bad,
it might not publish messages,
which is a good thing.
You don't have to worry
about the message coming in,
you don't have to worry
about any resiliency.
Then, they might still be live,
but they might start pushing in messages,
which may not be in the correct
format, which is a problem.
Either they have not been communicated
that there is a change
in your messaging pattern or structure,
or your most senior developer
has made the most simplest
of errors by making a field mandatory
in the messaging service.
Your messaging services can also go down,
because of either persistent
errors or transient errors.
And then, lastly, your
consumer can also be downed,
because of some networking problems,
or somebody forgot to deploy a service,
although, the CI/CD pipeline
said it is deployed.
So, during the talk,
we're gonna talk about all these patterns
and all these areas of failure
and address them through
architectural patterns.
(Parnab Basak clears throat)
To talk about it,
the first pattern that
we're gonna talk about,
is the dead-letter queue
pattern or the DLQ pattern.
And what this does is you have a producer,
in this case, I'm using Amazon SQS queue
as an intermediary messaging service.
Then, you have the consumer too.
So, if your messages are erroneous,
you can configure an
Amazon dead-letter queue,
which is nothing but a
simple standard queue
to push those messages to this queue.
You can implement this very easily
in your existing
application if you have one.
All you have to do is
define a dead-letter queue.
And even certain services
like AWS Lambda has the option
to configure dead-letter queues
in case you're able to pick up Lambda,
it's not able to process certain messages,
because of certain issues,
runtimes, code issues, bugs, et cetera,
and they can be pushed over
to a standard SQS queue
configured as a dead-letter queue.
Now, I always have a problem
with calling this as dead-letter queues.
These messages are not dead, okay?
So, somebody perhaps took this reference
from the old postal service systems
where messages were being,
all letters were being sent
and there was no recipients
or an incorrect address.
So, they didn't know what to do.
In this case, they are not dead.
I rather would call them
error message queue,
so that you as a developer,
you as an administrator,
you as a business owner can
intercept those messages,
either manually or through systematic way
and then republish them
back to the SQS queue
by correcting them.
Typical examples,
let's say, somebody has made
a field a mandatory one, okay?
Let's call it, the ID field is mandatory,
which was not previously.
So, anything that does not
have an ID can be sent back
to the producer
and then you can put in
an ID, an arbitrary one
to go process it.
And then, that redrive happens, sorry,
redrive happens back to
the original SQS queue
for it to be processed.
Again, Tom is going
to walk through the
dead-letter queue pattern
through his code.
We'll look at what
configurations you need,
what permissions you need
in order to configure dead-letter queues.
Has anybody implemented
a dead-letter queue
in their application before?
Wow!
Well, I shouldn't have talked
about this at such a length.
(Parnab laughs)
(Tom laughs)
Okay, anyways, for folks
that didn't use it,
probably, you get some value add
as we talk about this during
your code implementations.
The next pattern is what we call
as a retry with a backoff pattern, okay?
So, this is particularly
important for transient errors
that your message bus or your
consumer might end up having.
A typical example,
let's say, you have
temporary networking failure,
or you have a overload of messages
where you end up having service quotas.
Because of an erratic producer
producing too many messages.
So, in this case, what you end up doing,
is you kind of configure a retry
with a exponential backoff pattern
in which case, we are
publishing subsequent messages
with a time difference between them,
so that each subsequent message
is delayed to the matter.
And why you do it?
The primary reason for doing this,
is you are giving sufficient time
for your message service or your consumer
to keep up to its healthy state
before it can go receive messages.
So, that's the high-level idea.
Anybody using this retry
with backoff pattern?
Okay, I see a few folks all across.
Thank you for using it.
Certain services already
have this in-built.
For example, SNS, when it's
trying to publish messages
to multiple other endpoints,
has retry with backoff by
default configured within it.
Lambda also has this when it's
receiving messages from S3,
or publishing to other
services like SQS queues too.
You can of course override
them as you want to.
But that's a very nitty option
to have it already
configured as a part of it.
Now, let's talk about
some persistent errors.
We talked about transient errors.
Those appear and go away
without you doing much, okay?
What about some use cases
where you see the producer,
or the consumer having
more transient errors?
So, for example,
if your consumer ends up
having pertinent errors,
which is not recoverable
and which are not temporary,
then you can employ something,
called a circuit breaker pattern.
What the circuit breaker pattern does,
is if everything is fine,
the circuit is closed.
Taking an example from
an electrical systems.
But if there are issues like
a persistent error issue
with the consumer,
we call the circuit being open.
And what you can do in this scenario,
is you can use services
like AWS Step Functions,
or even Lambda functions, which
Tom would be going to show
during these code demonstrations
to push them to an SQS queue
again as a temporary store
and then have an Amazon
EventBridge Scheduler,
which is going to pull from
the messages from that queue
and then redrive them back
again, back to the consumer.
So, in this case, the circuit is open.
It's not handling in its irregular state.
But you have an option
to do health checks,
understand when the
consumer is back up and open
and then redrive those messages back
to the original consumer.
Anybody implemented
circuit breaker pattern?
Okay, I see one.
So, if you look at the patterns,
DLQ had the most adoption,
going by backoff with
retry being the next best,
circuit breaker pattern be
the third one there, okay?
Let's see how far we go down the route
and see how far that
option rate is currently.
But you may not have one consumer,
one consumer's circuit breaker
pattern works perfectly okay.
What about you trying to push
this to multiple consumers?
So, in this case, I have two consumers
and you want to have a
distributed transaction.
And what I mean by a
distributed transaction,
is your messaging service
wants to push this
to two consumers
and both the states of the
consumers should be committed
in order for the transaction
to entirely be successful, right?
So, you have two local transactions,
one going to consumer one.
But in this case, let's say the
consumer two is unavailable,
because a junior developer
is doing a deployment
outside the green zone, okay?
So, what happens in this case?
You have a system where it's inconsistent,
meaning your consumer one and
consumer two are out of state
and that's not an acceptable solution.
So, what you end up doing
is you kind of do this
with Step Functions
that you push or pull in
in between the messaging service
and Step Functions knows how
to compensate the transaction.
What I mean by it is if
Step Functions understands
that your consumer two is down,
what it can do is it can do
a compensatory transaction,
reverting the comment made to consumer one
and then store it again
either in a database system,
or on a totally different queue
or maybe even a DLQ, okay,
or maybe it might do a backoff
with retry pattern as well.
So, those are options and solutions
that you can go implement
and what we call this as a saga pattern,
specifically, a saga
orchestration pattern,
because we are orchestrating
between two consumers here.
Just for fun fact, this came,
the naming of this pattern came
from the fact that a saga
means a big, long, epic story
where each of the characters are episodes
within that story, unlike consumers here.
Again, in software engineering,
we seem to always get examples
from non-software things,
like electrical systems, post
offices and now epic stories.
Anyway, moving on to the last pattern
before we get into the code
is the redundancy pattern.
In the rare, uneventful case
that your infrastructure,
your messaging service may,
or may not be available because
of not a fault on your side.
You can definitely look
at the redundancy pattern.
Certain service like Amazon
MQ message broker allows you
to define an active standby pair
wherein you define two Amazon MQ brokers
in two separate availability zones
and then have an EFS file
system connected to it.
What happens during this scenario,
is if the primary goes down,
the standby can be quickly activated.
If you need more higher resiliencies
where you cannot afford the time it takes
to pull up the standby,
you can definitely look
at a multi-region,
multi-availability-zone ActiveMQ setup,
in which case you are looking
at a network of brokers
that are distributed and
deployed across all these regions
to enable zero downtime.
So, with that, I will conclude
my presentation, okay?
I hope this was understandable
and this is a good segue
to look at code, okay?
Tom, why don't you take it over?
- [Tom Romano] Okay, yeah,
let's take a look at some code.
So, before we dive into the code,
what I'm hoping to show you
today is that implementing some
of these patterns can
be done fairly easily
without really affecting
your main application code.
And to demonstrate that,
I built a little coffee
order processing system.
And it's very straightforward.
I can put in my name, I
can put in my coffee order,
I can submit my order.
And if everything works,
which it did, yay,
then a coffee is submitted.
And then I can go look at
my coffee order history,
pretty straight.
- [Parnab Basak] Are you
really getting coffees,
or it's just a demo?
- [Tom Romano] No, no, this
is just a demonstration.
We're getting virtual
coffee, simulated coffee.
And refresh the order history.
Ah, the demo gods are just
not working with us today.
So, I know why.
- [Parnab Basak] Should we start
by praying to the demo gods before we-
- [Tom Romano] Oh, absolutely, absolutely!
- [Parnab Basak] Okay,
what should the prayer be?
I know, I do this with
regular gods, but I'm no way-
- [Tom Romano] There we go, yep, yep.
Okay, so, we got our coffee
order, so we're good to go.
Awesome.
Look how quickly I fixed my demo.
That was, so, let's take a look
at what the architecture
looks behind the scenes here.
So, this is a pretty
straightforward consumer.
We've got, the producer is my
application that I created.
It's going through Amazon Gateway,
which is my API front door.
It logs a message directly to SQS
and then immediately returns.
So, I get very fast
response to my front end.
It's all decoupled.
This is good event-driven
architecture 101.
We could have any broker here.
I'm just gonna use SQS,
'cause it's convenient.
And then, our consumer
in the background is a Lambda function,
which is a serverless compute function
that is processing the coffee orders.
And as part of that, it does two things.
The first thing it does is
it sends the payment out
to an external payment system.
And then, it will place the coffee order,
which for now, just places the
record in a database table.
But our external payment
system often goes down
for maintenance.
Anyone have this problem?
Yep.
Okay, so, and it typically goes down
for maintenance during a "re:Invent" talk.
So, we'll simulate that too.
So, for example, just to demonstrate this,
I can inject a fault.
So, I'm gonna do a fault injection
and break my payment system.
And then, when I go to order
and I'll order Parnab a few coffees.
- [Parnab Basak] Yeah,
I want that coffee, FYI
without being paid.
- [Tom Romano] I will get
it after the presentation.
I'll submit a few orders.
Okay, you notice that the API
responses are going through.
But when I go to look at order history,
Parnab is not getting his coffee.
The payment system is down,
coffees are not happening.
So, we need to evolve this architecture
to accommodate for this.
And not only it's part of
not getting his coffee,
but let's look at what's going
on behind the scenes here.
I'm gonna go look at my
observability in CloudWatch.
And I submitted my coffee
order, boom, great,
that's how it should look, okay?
But when I look at my message numbers,
I only ordered three coffees
and look at all these messages.
Every 10 seconds, I'm
getting another six messages?
Wow, that's a lot of messages
for just three coffees.
Imagine if this was like Starbucks
with thousands of orders.
I can see that my SQS
depth is staying at three.
Those three messages are
just getting recycled
over and over and over
for those three coffees.
But what's worse is what's
happening with Lambda.
For three cups of coffee,
look at all these invocations.
Invocation, by the way, is
the area underneath the curve.
I'm getting lots of Lambda invocations
and those invocations are
for 30 seconds an invocation.
That's my timeout on my Lambda functions.
So, what's happening?
I'm spending a lot of
compute and getting nowhere.
It's just cycling over
and over these messages.
- [Parnab Basak] And I'm not
getting my coffee as well.
- [Tom Romano] And you're
still not getting your coffee.
It's still gonna be a while
before you get your coffee.
We're just gonna improve this first.
- [Parnab Basak] Okay.
- [Tom Romano] So, from a
cost-optimization standpoint,
I don't want my system
to go out of control
in a failure situation.
I do not want it to go out of control.
I want it to land well.
So, that's why I want to add the DLQ.
So, I'm gonna add a little
bit of architecture here.
As Parnab mentioned, I'm gonna add a DLQ
and so that when a single
message is retried three times,
it'll be automatically moved to the DLQ.
The other thing I wanna do is be able
to redrive those messages
back into the main order queue
when my payment system comes back up.
This sounds like a lot of
work, but it's really not.
And that's because there
are features built into SQS
that can really help us with
some of this implementation,
so that I really don't have
to modify my application much.
Okay, code, yay!
Let's not look at that.
So, I've been using Kiro,
I don't know, has anyone been using Kiro?
I'm like really into it.
I was a VS Code person before.
- [Parnab Basak] Yeah, that's awesome.
Nobody has used Kiro,
okay, which is great.
And you get to see a live
coding how Kiro performs
and you can downvote Kiro, upvote Kiro
in your comments too as we go down.
- [Tom Romano] Yeah, Kiro's available now.
Okay, so, behind my application,
it's infrastructure as code.
Can everyone see that okay?
It's a little hard.
- [Parnab Basak] Yeah.
- [Tom Romano] It's about
as big as I can make-
- [Parnab Basak] Actually, folks
in the last row see that okay?
Thumbs up?
Cool.
- [Tom Romano] Okay, just
wanted to make sure, oops.
So, this is my queue, this
is my current order queue.
That's where the coffee orders all go.
And to add a DLQ,
what we do is we just
create another queue.
And you could do this with anything,
any other messaging service.
And yeah, I actually,
I just hit pound and Kiro said,
"Oh, do you want a DLQ with this?"
And it's like, "Thanks."
So, yeah, we'll take that.
(Tom laughs)
I'm not gonna argue, but let
me walk through the code.
So, I'm gonna create an OrderDLQ,
which is a standard SQS queue,
nothing special about it,
except my message retention
period is 1,209,600 seconds,
or 14 days.
Why did I do that, Parnab?
- [Parnab Basak] I want to get coffee
for the next 14 days for free?
(Tom laughs)
- [Tom Romano] Oh, well, not quite that,
but I need to give myself time to recover.
- [Parnab Basak] Oh, okay.
- [Tom Romano] Yeah, so,
I wanna give myself the time it takes
to notice that the system's
down and recover the system.
So, I'm gonna let this queue messages sit
in this queue for a longer period of time.
Okay, well, that's great, Tom.
You've got a DLQ.
Now, you've gotta go modify
your application, right?
Nope, it's built into SQS.
So, I can go back over
to my normal SQS queue
and I can create a redrive policy.
And when I create a redrive policy,
wow, I don't have to type it all, do I?
When I create my redrive
policy, you specify two things.
First, where you want
those dead-letter messages
to go, what queue
and I wanna send them to my OrderDLQ
and then a maxReceiveCount,
which is like how many
times do I wanna retry
before I move them over to the DLQ.
And give them a couple of tries,
give them two or three.
But then move them over to the DLQ.
And yeah, Kiro really helped me out there.
Now, the other thing I need to do,
is grant it some permissions
and not really wanting to
type in front of everyone.
'Cause I never had to type in class.
I'm just gonna uncomment this.
But basically, what I'm doing now,
is giving my functions access
to the dead-letter queue
and we'll see why I do that later.
So, just giving some permissions.
And then, the final thing I'm going to do,
is send the dead-letter
queue's name and URL,
or ARN and URL over
to my Lambda functions
and environment variables.
That way, my Lambda functions
now know about the DLQ.
They don't have to yet,
but let's just do that.
That's it.
That's all you have to
do to your application.
But now, we do need a redrive function.
So, we need to be able to recover this.
So, I have a Lambda function
that's already kind of a shell
and this Lambda function
is not implemented yet.
But if you can see on my screen,
this is the main logic of it.
It comes in and I have this class,
called test_payment_with_canary_success.
This is part of the pattern
you wanna put in your redrive.
The first thing you wanna do,
is see if your dependency is available.
Because one thing you
don't wanna do is redrive,
or send all those messages
back to be processed
if your downstream system is broken.
So, do a check, do a canary check,
make sure that system's healthy.
And if it is, great.
Once I'm sure that that's healthy,
I can then redrive the messages.
And to do that, I'm going
to use a feature of SQS.
SQS has the ability to pick
messages up for one queue
and deposit them into another
at a rate that you specify automatically.
You don't have to do it manually.
You can just tell SQS, "Go, do it."
And so, we're gonna
use that functionality.
So, I am going to type response,
just so I have a place for
the response of the API call.
And no matter what language you're using,
there is a AWS SDK with
a SQS client in it.
I'm using Python, so, I've got Boto3.
And I'm going to use the
start_message_move_task.
This is the API called the SQS,
that'll move messages from
one queue to the other.
And it takes just two really parameters
that you absolutely need,
which is SourceQueueUrl,
that's where to move messages from
and DestinationQueueUrl where's to.
Now, generative AI is often
helpful and sometimes, it's not.
And it has reversed how I want to do this.
(Tom laughs)
So, I want to move things
from the dead-letter queue
to my order queue.
And I don't wanna move just 10 messages,
I really wanna move them all.
There's a different parameter
I want to use here, which is,
sorry, it just went out of my head.
Number of messages per second.
There we go.
And this specifies how fast
you wanna move everything over.
So, I'm gonna do it,
actually, I'll just do it
at one message per second.
And I'll spell it right.
There we go.
And then, last thing I'm gonna do,
is I'm just gonna make sure
that it actually started that task.
And so, I'm gonna say,
it returns a task handle.
And so, if the task
handle is in the response,
I can say that the redrive
task started successfully,
otherwise, it didn't.
Any questions on that?
Pretty straightforward?
- [Parnab Basak] So, basically,
what you're doing, Tom,
is you're trying to redrive
the messages back from the DLQ
to over to the actual queue,
assuming that the consumer
is now back alive.
- [Tom Romano] Correct.
- [Parnab Basak] Okay.
- [Tom Romano] Yep.
- [Parnab Basak] Yes, sir?
- [Tom Romano] Question?
- [Parnab Basak] Can you
show us the canary success?
- [Tom Romano] Oh, the success check?
- [Parnab Basak] Okay.
- [Tom Romano] Yep, we can do that.
- [Parnab Basak] The question,
is can we show us the
canary success check,
how we are doing it in the original code?
Again, this is Python, but again,
I think that's the most
easiest language to understand.
So, if you are a developer
from other languages,
just follow us along.
There are equivalents of these-
- [Tom Romano] Okay.
- [Parnab Basak] Available
in Java, .NET and-
- [Tom Romano] So, this is my canary.
And what the canary does
is it sends a test order,
an order that the payment
system will ignore
when it receives it,
but it's basically full up testing it out.
It's sending an order for
zero just to make sure,
it's like a heartbeat check.
And I could do a lot with this.
I could find out what the delay is.
I could measure latency.
I could, yeah, see what
the response time is.
So, basically, I've negotiated
with the payment system
to ignore this particular test message.
And I can send it whenever I want.
- [Parnab Basak] The best piece
I love is the amount is 0.0.
- [Tom Romano] Yep.
- [Parnab Basak] That's the
only thing that matters, yes?
- [Tom Romano] That's what I'm doing.
- [Audience Member 1] Is
there some sort of TTL,
being managed for you
and so, you don't end up
getting a forever loop or-
- [Tom Romano] Yes, there was, oops-
- [Parnab Basak] The question is,
is there a TTL for the loop for canary
to ensure that you're
not checking the health
of the system too many times?
- [Audience Member 1] No, no, no.
It's just so the message
doesn't get redrived
and move between queues a 4 billion times.
- [Tom Romano] Ah, okay, yep,
move between queues a number of times.
So, when I did the redrive-
- [Parnab Basak] You want
to repeat the question?
- [Tom Romano] So, the question,
was how do you stop the messages
from constantly bouncing back and forth
between the DLQ and the actual queue?
And that's really taken
care of in the redrive logic
by ensuring that the
system is ready and able
to handle those messages
before I send them back
to the order queue.
So, I verify that that
order queue will work
and will process those before
I send them over there.
And that's key.
Sometimes, I've seen implementations
where they don't do that.
And yeah, you get a
bouncing back and forth.
- [Audience Member 2] Right,
what if is the problem with
the actual message itself
that the logic is gonna
be built is bouncing back?
- [Tom Romano] What if the problem,
is with the actual message itself
and it continues to get
bounced back and forth?
- [Parnab Basak] That's
a very good question.
Okay, so, the way we have implemented one
of the best practice there
is there are two use cases
that you can do multiple DLQ patterns.
One is for messages that
need manual intervention,
either from developers,
sysadmins, ops, et cetera,
to be able to make a
correction on those messages.
That's a separate DLQ.
And the other DLQ can be a queue
where you are just parking the messages
in order for them to be processed later
when the source systems becomes healthy.
For example, in this case,
the payment system becomes healthy.
So, that's a divide and conquer approach.
You cannot just have one
single DLQ to handle everything
from manual intervention,
schema mismatches,
or service unavailability.
- [Tom Romano] Okay,
so, I deployed my DLQ.
And I'm gonna show you this,
but then I'm gonna show you
another kind of view of this.
Remember that we had ordered some coffees?
- [Parnab Basak] Yeah.
- [Tom Romano] And they
were bouncing around?
Well, as soon as I deployed my DLQ,
it's starting to get back under control.
You can see the numbers
are starting to dip down.
But let me show you maybe
a cleaner view of that.
So, here's the behavior with DLQ.
So, first of all,
I don't have that continual
bouncing of messages.
Things get under control
relatively quickly.
But the more important story,
is what's happening with Lambda.
Yes, I'm getting a few
executions of 30 seconds,
but not continuously.
I'm not getting Lambda storms,
I'm not spinning my wheels trying to,
they're moving over to the DLQ.
And even though Parnab still
doesn't have his coffee-
- [Parnab Basak] Yep.
- [Tom Romano] Right?
- [Parnab Basak] I don't.
- [Tom Romano] You still
don't have your coffee.
And this is where we again
pray to the demo gods,
we're gonna do a redrive,
which gave me an error.
So, I wasn't able to show that on that.
But what we would do is we
would redrive it right over
to the messages.
Not wanting you to be left without,
let's do a redrive demo.
So, basically, what we're going
to do now is with the DLQ,
we're gonna take the
messages that were in the DLQ
and use the redrive function
to redrive them back to the event queue.
So, we'll break the system,
order a few coffees.
Submit that.
I'll submit a few.
- [Parnab Basak] So, DLQ
test needs three coffees now?
- [Tom Romano] Yeah.
- [Parnab Basak] And I don't get any?
- [Tom Romano] You don't get any.
- [Parnab Basak] That's not good.
- [Tom Romano] Okay.
Yep, we see the system behavior
gets under control quick.
The messages drop off quickly.
Our Lambda function is in control.
So, a little bit of processing
there, but not too bad.
Now, I can go fix my payment system
and redrive the orders.
So, it starts the redrive process.
If I go look at order history,
we start to see, it starts
to redrive those messages,
one coffee a second.
So, there's the first order.
The second order has arrived.
And they're all coming
out of the redrive queue.
So, that's the demo about how it works.
- [Parnab Basak] Okay, before
we move into the next pattern,
any questions?
Is there anything that we are missing here
that we should be implementing?
Yes, sir?
- [Audience Member 3]
I'm a security officer
and (indistinct) manual redrive,
I have an operator and I see some stuff
in my (indistinct)
redrive guidance program.
I've (indistinct) there
something not quite (indistinct).
- [Parnab Basak] So, the
question that has that,
is there an option in the console
for manual redrive of
messages back to the queue,
which needs manual intervention?
So, a message comes in
probably for coffee,
maybe the coffee type was not mentioned
and that's a mandatory message.
It gets pushed over to the DLQ.
And somebody needs to
actually really tell, okay,
"Parnab needs mocha and not latte," right?
Okay and then once you
go change that feeling,
that what's the option to do it?
You wanna answer the question?
- [Tom Romano] No, I'm good.
- [Parnab Basak] Okay, cool.
(Tom laughs)
So, the way to do this,
yes, you have this
option to do this, okay?
So, you have, there is a,
I think, AWS Samples also have a utility
by which you can point it
to your dead-letter queues
in this in the samples
by which I don't think
there is a direct way
to make a change on the
message in the console, okay?
You have to create some
utility of your own.
And I think there are
a few samples out there
that gives you the option to do this
where you configure the DLQ
and as well as the target queue
to be able to push those messages, okay?
Because AWS Console does
not give any options
to make any changes to the
messages through the console.
It shows you the messages,
the structure of it.
- [Tom Romano] Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- [Parnab Basak] And count of it, okay?
How it looks like.
But there is no other
options to change them live
and then be able to
redirect them back again.
Any other questions?
Yes, sir.
(Audience Member 4 speaks indistinctly)
So, what is the, the
question that he has is,
so, how are you pulling up the messages
from the DLQ to be able to push them back
into the standard queue?
Is it by age, is it by count of messages,
is it by message type?
Did I get your question right?
- [Audience Member 4]
Use the native redrive,
does it use properties,
for example, the age,
the initial age, rather the
age when it was pushed back
from the DLQ to the main order queue?
- [Parnab Basak] Hmm.
- [Audience Member 4]
So, is it a new message,
or is it the same message
and these properties are basically kept?
- [Parnab Basak] Yeah, so
the message, if you are,
so the question that he has,
is let's say you are pushing in a message
to the regular queue
and that message gets
pushed over to the DLQ.
What happens with the age of the message,
some of the properties there?
So, essentially, the
message is kept as is.
There are some additional
metadata properties
that get changed for that messages.
But these are two different messages
in two different queues there, okay?
So, let's say, message A,
original message has a
timestamp of 10:45, okay?
And then when you push the messages over
to the standard queue or DLQ,
it probably will have a 10:46
with the different timestamp.
But the contents of the
messages will remain as is,
unless you are making
manual changes to it.
Okay?
So, what you define as
the message is important.
- [Tom Romano] And if order is important,
if your order queue is FIFO,
then your DLQ needs to be FIFO.
- [Parnab Basak] Yes.
So, some of the best practices there,
so, Amazon SQS also supports
a first-in, first-out queue
in which the ordering
of which they were
published in is maintained.
So, if your original queue,
is an Amazon Simple Queuing Service,
first-in, first-out queue,
probably a best practice
is to use a similar DLQ
to maintain the ordering.
- [Tom Romano] Okay.
Let's switch to the next architecture.
And what we're gonna do is evolve the DLQ.
Oh, there's one more question.
- [Parnab Basak] Oh, sorry, yeah?
- [Audience Member 5] So, in
terms of triggering the drive-
- [Parnab Basak] Redrive.
- [Audience Member 5] Redrive,
so, what's the best practice?
(Audience Member 5 speaks indistinctly)
How do you work out that?
- [Tom Romano] Great question.
I'm actually gonna share
you a couple of options
in the circuit breaker.
- [Parnab Basak] So, let
me repeat the question.
- [Tom Romano] Yep.
- [Parnab Basak] So, what
is the best time to redrive?
At what frequency should
I redrive these messages
from the DLQ back to the original queue?
What's a good practice there?
How soon, how frequently,
how infrequently should we do that?
And Parnab's, no, Tom's
response like any other SAs is-
- [Tom Romano] It depends.
- [Parnab Basak] It depends.
(Tom laughs)
And with that,
he's going to talk about
some other architectures
that talks about that in mind.
- [Tom Romano] Yeah, I do,
I wanna extend the DLQ architecture now
into the circuit breaker architecture.
And also, I wanna start
looking at self-healing.
Like how do we make the
redrive happen automatically,
so that I don't have to press the button
and I don't get called?
And then, what you have
is a self-healing system.
That's the dream.
- [Parnab Basak] Yep, let's-
- [Tom Romano] You want-
- [Parnab Basak] Yeah-
- [Tom Romano] You don't wanna get paid.
- [Parnab Basak] Why
don't we get to the dream?
- [Tom Romano] Yes, so,
the first thing I need,
is I need a circuit breaker.
And I've implemented a
circuit breaker for us just
in the name of expediency
and it's a controlled database
and I've got four methods here.
I've got a method that says,
"Is the circuit open, true or false?
Is the circuit closed, true or false,"
which is the opposite.
And then I have a method that
will open the circuit breaker,
which means something went wrong.
And then,
I have a method that will
close the circuit breaker,
which means everything is good.
Behind the scenes, it's
just a DynamoDB table,
it's actually just an
item in a DynamoDB table.
DynamoDB is really good for this.
It's a quick key value lookup-
- [Parnab Basak] Yep.
- [Tom Romano] That you
can put cache in front of.
So, it's really good
for this kind of stuff.
So, I've got a circuit_breaker_payment
item in my database
and the circuit's currently closed.
So, to add the circuit breaker,
I do need to add a little
bit more architecture.
I don't have any more moving pieces,
but I have a bit more logic.
In my consumer,
what I wanna do is see if
the circuit's open first.
If it is open, then I
don't want to process.
I want to assume I'm just gonna fail.
Because someone before me has determined
that the payment system's not good
and I just need to like fail fast.
If I call the payment service in error,
then I need to open the circuit
and send it to the dead-letter
queue for a later processing.
So, I need to do a little bit more work
in my order-processing Lambda.
The only thing that I need
to change in my redrive,
is if I notice that the service is up,
I need to close the circuit breaker
and allow messages to flow again.
So, it's sort of the pairing of the two
that open and close the circuit.
I open the circuit in my consumer,
I close the circuit in my redrive.
Okay, let's implement this.
- [Parnab Basak] Let's do the video,
show the video directly.
- [Tom Romano] Okay.
We've had some great questions
and we're a little short on time.
So, I'm actually just
gonna do the video of it
if that's okay.
So, we're gonna look
in our order processor.
And when you come into
our order processor,
it just asks for the payment.
So, what we wanna do is see
if the circuit breaker
is currently closed.
If it's closed, go ahead
and try the payment.
Otherwise, it's open
and I'm just gonna go ahead
and raise my payment processing error.
I'll just raise an error.
So, you just need
to wrap your logic
around a circuit breaker.
If you get an error, you wanna
open your circuit breaker.
The next thing you wanna
do is send the message
to your dead-letter queue manually.
Because you weren't able to process it
and you need to catch it and
you need to send it yourself.
So, I'm gonna send this message over
and I'm just gonna send
my whole order over.
So, I'm just gonna dump the whole order
over into the message body.
The other thing that I want to do,
is rather than raise an error
and fail out of the whole Lambda,
I'm just gonna keep processing.
I'm gonna return a stub that says,
"Well, you can get your coffee,
but you haven't paid for it yet."
So, I'm going to fail
deprecated rather than fail.
And I've moved my message
to the dead-letter queue
and I'll process that payment later.
And that way, Parnab will
get his coffee right away.
- [Parnab Basak] Finally.
- [Tom Romano] So, that's the
only change you need to make
to the order processing.
Basically, check that
the circuit is closed
before you actually implement.
And if it fails,
open the circuit and send
it to the dead-letter queue.
For the redrive, the
change is very simple.
When I go to my redrive function,
if the canary succeeds, close
the circuit, that simple.
It's working, close the circuit,
allow processing to flow again.
And that is literally the
only change I need to make
to my redrive.
But we wanna automatically recover, right?
What we can do is we can
schedule our redrive function
to automatically run.
And it will check the
payment processing system.
So, what I'll do is I'll just schedule it
to run automatically.
I'm just gonna add an EventBridge schedule
to that Lambda function.
And I'll have it run every minute
and I'll call it PeriodicRedrive.
So, every minute,
it's gonna see "Is the
payment service up?"
Great, redrive.
It's not gonna redrive anything
if there's nothing to redrive.
And that will make my system
entirely self-healing.
Do you wanna do it every minute?
Probably not.
I'm just doing that
for demo purposes here.
But that's the only change
that you need to make.
- [Parnab Basak] So, coming
back to his question,
what should be a good redrive policy
to redrive your messages back,
or check the health of the scheduler?
"Depends on your system,"
like an SA would always,
always say, right?
And that depends on the criticality of it.
How soon do you think you need to process?
For example, financial transactions,
probably cannot handle
a per-minute redrive.
Coffee orders can.
Okay, for example, I can
survive more than a minute
without having coffee.
So, what's your schedule,
probably would depend
on the criticality of
the messages in there
and what do you think is your
RT or recovery time objective,
or recovery point objective there.
So, what is your defined time
in which you have to process messages?
- [Tom Romano] Yeah and we
can see that behavior here.
Just gonna order, I'm gonna
break the system again,
order a couple of coffees.
The first coffee's gonna trip the breaker.
So, I'll submit that order.
So, right now, the circuit's open.
The coffee will come through,
it'll go through the event queue,
the circuit will be closed,
it'll try the payment service,
it'll trip, open the circuit
and send it to the DLQ.
So, if I go and I look at my
coffee and see what happened
and look at my order history,
I did get the coffee,
but I got it with the payment
status of circuit open,
until I haven't actually
processed the payment.
It's sitting in the dead-letter
queue partially processed.
(Parnab Basak coughs)
Okay?
My subsequent coffees, the
circuit breaker's already open,
those are gonna fail fast.
I'll see those coffees immediately,
but again, without the order processing.
I see my coffees immediately.
But the circuit's open, I'm
not processing my payments.
Behind the scenes,
when I look at what's
going on with CloudWatch,
I can see my system stays
very much under control.
I get that initial push
where it's trying and fails.
But look at my Lambda processing duration.
I get that one hit at 30 seconds
and subsequent hits are very fast,
very efficient from a Lambda perspective.
Now, I can do my redrive.
So, when the service is
up, it'll close the circuit
and automatically redrive my coffees,
therefore, reprocessing
those payment systems.
Remember, that I've got the
payment status of circuit open.
So, let's go ahead and
fix our payment system.
And since I have the
automatic redrive happening,
I don't have to press the redrive button.
It's automatically going to detect
that the payment service
is now available again
and automatically redrive those coffees
and process the payments.
And so, I still see
that the coffees haven't been
quite processed quite yet.
'Cause remember, that I'm
moving one message a second.
So, it's gonna take a few seconds.
But if I refresh again,
I'll start to see that the
coffees are indeed processed.
And now, they're all fully processed.
My system is self-recovered
and self-healed,
once the payment system came back up.
- [Parnab Basak] Okay, so, Tom,
the TLD that get from this,
is design your systems
to be self-recordable and self-healing.
Design your systems
to be resilient across multiple
different types of errors.
It might be a messaging error,
configuration or other types of errors.
What else do you think
we should be looking at
as takeaways from this session?
- [Tom Romano] Well, if
you design for failure,
then nothing fails.
- [Parnab Basak] Right.
- [Tom Romano] Because
it's just the behavior
of your system.
Your system is able to accommodate it,
it's able to continue working
and continue servicing your customers,
even though there might be a degradation.
- [Parnab Basak] So,
again, thank you everyone
for attending this session.
Again, if you didn't know,
we have the session reviews
that you can go to in
the mobile app, okay,
which is super, super useful for us.
Again, as you can tell,
this is a brand-new talk
that we ended up doing this "re:Invent".
It's never been done before.
But if you like the
session, like the content
and found that this was useful,
please give us your honest feedback.
That is a big, big component for us
to learn from your direct feedback
and improve this going forward.
And again, we look forward
to meeting more of you,
or using these AWS services.
If you didn't know an
AWS solutions architect,
probably, you can reach out to us
and we will give you our numbers, contacts
to help you build on
AWS messaging services.
But if you have to take three
things back from this session,
probably these are the three things.
Idempotent messages is something
that you should really, really look at,
so that respective of,
you can retry, resend, republish
those messages any number
of times,
should look at redundancy in
terms of your infrastructure,
not only regional availability
zone-based redundancy,
but message handling redundancy too,
like we talked about regular
queues for pushing messages,
another queue for pushing a
different actionable messages,
et cetera.
And look at your operational excellence.
How are you stimulating those
in your DEV, UAT, pre-PROD environments
to be able to not incorporate these
in your production environments?
Again, these are just four of
the architectural patterns-
- [Tom Romano] Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- [Parnab Basak] That we
had time to talk about.
There are a few more that we have in mind,
which we've seen some
usages and applications of.
So, given what we have as
a one-hour presentation,
we could only probably show two
and talk about five,
talk about four of these.
So, hopefully, this was a good session.
And enjoy "re:Invent",
just pick up all the fun, all
the quirkiness of "re:Invent".
Probably, I find this super useful,
even from me being an
AWS solutions architect.
Thank you, everyone.
- [Tom Romano] Thank you very much.